new announcement from british airways
british airways has informed pilots and
the cabin crew
that they need to stop the hate hateful
language the hate speech
that passengers so often encounter on
their airplanes do you know what hate
speech i'm talking about
uh three words
ladies
and gentlemen
so when you get on a british airways
flight let's say i don't i can't i keep
really blowing my british accents these
days but i don't know something to the
effect of well hello there governor
ladies and gentlemen welcome on to the
flight yeah yeah i don't know i assume
that's i haven't flown british airways
but they will it's very nice very
civilized to say hello welcome ladies
and gentlemen welcome to your flight uh
please buckle your seatbelt we'll be
serving drinks very shortly well you're
not allowed to say that anymore and this
is because they want to promote quote
diversity and inclusion
according to the telegraph the
announcement came over the past few
weeks
and the pilots and the cabin crews were
told to use gender neutral language now
i don't what gender neutral language
are they going to use you're not you're
no longer a lady or a gentleman
presumably you can't be called a man or
a woman
what are you going to be called meat bag
hey
hey
meat bag hey flesh
flesh sack
hey what i don't know because you're the
the things that distinguish you that
seem to elevate you above the animals
that you're a lady that you're a
gentleman at least that you're a man or
a woman
those are no longer acceptable hey
person
well son though son is sexist paper
per daughter
paper daughter is that what you're going
to be called i don't think so
in a way british airways is right to do
this because we are no longer a society
of ladies and gentlemen we are
increasingly
a barbaric society where we
don't forget the word barbarism just
comes from this idea of foreigners
speaking a language that you don't
understand and they all sound like
they're saying
that's actually where the word comes
from and increasingly that's what
our society feels like to us people are
saying things that don't mean anything
we don't speak a common language we
don't view ourselves and the world in
the same way
and i'm reminded of edmund burke you
know edmund burke has that famous line
and the reflections on the revolution in
france he says the age of chivalry is
gone that of sofasters economists and
calculators has succeeded it and the
glory of europe is extinguished forever
and he's he talks specifically about how
no more will we have that
duty that sense of loyalty that proud
submission of rank and sex you know this
this idea that would keep
an exalted freedom alive even even in
servitude itself that is gone
that that actually is gone and it's too
bad last night we were at the ryman we
did a backstage live show it was a ton
of fun thanks to everyone who came out
we had a really really great time and
someone asked what's the surest sign
that civilization is on the decline and
uh the question was not to me it was to
someone else and we were trying to move
quickly through these questions but it
seems to me the answer is
when
men stop holding the door whether it's
the door to a building or the door to a
car you know or men's not picking up the
tab or
when men stop treating women with a
special sort of respect and vice versa
for that matter and the reason for this
is
that these are the
ornamentations of life
that represent an entire developed
sophisticated serious
social system
right and that kind of care is gone
there is something i didn't even start
doing this until at least in my 20s
there's something nice about a man
opening up the car door for a woman it
will delay you all right when you when
you've got to get out of the house you
got to go somewhere that's you and your
wife are you and your girlfriend or you
and whoever just some chick and you're
walking if you just each walk to your
own door and just get in quickly and
turn the car on you'll get you'll leave
faster
but there's something less dignified
there's something a little utilitarian a
little a little savage
if if you'll allow me that perhaps
hyperbole about that sort of thing take
the minute take the time
take the time for these these
little ornamentations that that make
life a little bit more civilized you
know when we when we sit down to eat
dinner
we can either sit down put our napkin on
our lap say grace
you know look look greet everybody pour
wine make sure everyone has their own
food then pick up our knife and fork and
start eating our food or we can just
like shove our faces in our slot buckets
and you know not did not do any of those
things and i guess it would be faster
and more efficient and utilitarian to do
it in the latter way but it would not be
civilized it would not be civil and
that's that's what it's very sad to see
this from british airways because i
think we in america always think of the
brits as being a little more
sophisticated than we are but their
priorities are now out of order i'm so
glad you liked that clip if you don't
mind
leave me a comment say you like the clip
that's very sweet of you
and uh subscribe and ring the bell and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show subscribe leave a five star
review i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you